you got time to do uh the stevie wonder  song you're gonna do superstition or do  you you guys too busy  do you feel like doing it yeah yeah  that'd be uh i mean it's uh why not i  think people are digging this  [Music]  very superstitious  writings on the wall  very superstition  ladders bout to fall  13 months old baby  [Music]  [Music]  good things in your past  when you believe in things  that you don't understand and you're  suffering  [Music]  superstition  [Music]  wash your face and hands  [Music]  rip me up my problems  do all that you can  [Music]  keep me in a daydream  [Music]  come on keep it going strong  [Music]  you don't want to save me  sad  [Music]  a superstition ain't the way  [Music]  um  [Music]  [Music]  the devil's on his way  [Music]  seven years  the things in your pace  hey  [Music]  wow great job boys  you